e
mon
oh
fois mon traîneau dans la neige dans la
neige et les grelots dans la neige flanc
blanc blanc va montrer nos sous la neige
en vol
j'ai un grand manteau de neige blanc
blanc blanc le loup dans sa chaumière
s'éteindre au feu de bois lamiaux dans
la frairie là bas lui se croiser les
bras femme au créneau dans la neige dans
la neige et les grelots dans la neige
blanc blond blanc va montrer nos sous la
neige folle folle j'ai un grand manteau
de neige blanc blanc blanc et je prends
ma guitare saturée show fera les doigts
je m'en vais réveiller l'a fait elle
doit être par là pas mon traîneau dans
la neige dans la neige et les grelots
dans la neige blanche
va montrer nos sous la neige volvo j'ai
un grand manteau de neige blanc blanc
blanc regarde les étoiles et le nuage en
coton blanc le vent ici la voile ou
c'est par le printemps pas le printemps
une de traîneau dans la neige vu de
neige puni de chrono dans la neige blanc
blanc blanc le traîneau penthalaz pi2 à
la neige le grelot dans la remise tort
doucement
foncez bien attristant voilà le
printemps
quant aux nouvelles
ouais ouais
de jeu
les usa
ça va quant aux
nouvelles
elle
des musiques
du monde
szavay
m
et quant aux
nouvelles
le camp nou est
ouais ouais
tg
du jaune saveur
quant aux
nouvelles
joseph amant
arrivé du quai
être
devant
allez dre
à jouer et quant aux
nouvelles
le camp nou est
nous elle où elle
tg
du zoo
on savait
quant aux
nouvelles
à djeddah
marie kanté
paris
hank est né
mickey et quant aux
nouvelles
quant aux nouvelles
nous à nous elle
de jeu
usant
quand noël
à
voilà
où
e
ouais
il fait froid le marron et glacé il
c'est froid le citron pj vrai il fait
doux près de la cheminée
et partout le bon grain et l'ivraie
et chez nous dans la maison qui chanteur
on attend mieux qu'un prince charmant
aujourd'hui c'est la fête touchante de
noël au bois dormant
écoutez j'entends le père noël qui
descend dans notre cheminée au mais non
c'est le père de joel qui est venu
ramoné il fait froid le marron et glace
et il fait froid le citron est givrée il
fait doux près de la cheminée
et partout le bon grain et l'ivraie
père noël mon vieux tu exagères
montre toi j'aimerai te voir on dit que
pour pas qu'on te repères du ap un tabac
voir
au charbon ne va pas te brûler au
chardon ne va pas te guérit fait
attention le marron et griet mais le bon
grain et l'ivraie
il fait chaud le bon vin est tiré il
fait chaud bonbons fondant ronde et et
pourtant on caille sur canapé est
partout l'omelette des plans b
jusqu'en norvège
je
l'hiver est vert dans ses lumières
l'ordre m'absenter au dessus des toits
mes yeux de hibou
paisible et plan contempler tous des
tanières
des bruits assourdissants de l'hiver
les tentacules
du crépuscule
amène des chiens pouvez garer sur les
radeaux n'obtient deux éclairs
duranleau font des lampadaires
dégaine fruits de l'hiver
point sur la hanche et la nuit se
pencher encore tandis que la lune glisse
et contre quelques crachats d'entre qui
crise n allons pas lent elle est la
pierre
les refuges de ses repères
sous le silence
de ces patients sont les vivants ont le
temps de voyager sous la voûte crânienne
endommagées par les secondes qui
altèrent les peintures sous nos
paupières
faudra que l'aube
neuf sa robe et la jette au dessus de
son visage puisqu'il faut faire à chacun
sont partagés mais le métal du matin que
l'artère fluide de noël
il va révéler
dans ses lumières
blanc je m'absentais
au dessus des toits mes yeux de hibou
petit bleu et blanc contemplent
le trou des tanières des bruit assourdi
de l'hiver
à
là
parent
e
ne t'en fais pas
pas trop
à
9h20 ces dépressions